I'm here with Walter Matt wait Chuck who
is presenting at stoic on again and he's
also a rebt
practitioner you there's quite a few
other things that you do to your your
teaching you have a practice right it's
I'm a clinical psychologist and I
practice that's the thing I do mostly I
do that about 30 hours a week but I also
teach at New York University I practice
at the University of Pennsylvania and I
also train students doctoral students
who are becoming psychologists so I
trained them in rational emotive
behavior therapy that must keep you
extraordinary yes it does but I'm very
passionate about my work it's actually I
I love doing it I see myself as a
descent disseminator of rebt I'd like to
pass down I've had the good fortune of
being trained by the person who
originated Albert Ellis and so having
worked with him and actually you also
the other person known in the cognitive
behavioral world Tim Beck dr. Beck
between these two I've had the good
fortune of studying with the two most
well known cognitive behavioral
psychologists two people the people who
actually assured in the paradigm shift
from psychoanalysis
so yeah actually that's something we
should talk about as well because I
think a lot of people don't know any of
that back story about how psychoanalysis
was just sort of dominating the
psychotherapy scene for so long but can
you lay out what the difference between
rational emotive behavior therapy and
and the more well-known I think at this
time cognitive behavioral therapy is and
some of these other cognitive approaches
right so so you should first start with
the idea that both of these psycho
therapies are cognitive behavioral
psychotherapy so initially Albert called
his therapy rational therapy and then
changed the to rational emotive therapy
and then rebranded it finally to
rational emotive behavior therapy back
on the other hand started with cognitive
therapy for depression changed it to
cognitive therapy for other disorders
anxiety and substance abuse so he was
developing different cognitive therapies
and then more recently people began to
call that cognitive behavior therapy but
really cognitive behavioral therapy is a
generic term okay under that fall
different cognitive behavioral therapies
one of which is rational emotive
behavior therapy okay so why was it so
important that there was a shift to this
you might say out of and in some
respects against the psychoanalytic
establishment well it was important
because the traditional psycho
analytical model as you say was
predominant and it was important because
it was radical Ellis was dissatisfied he
actually had two practices one where he
did classic psychoanalysis this is 1950
say four and one where he did sex and
love and relationship counseling and
that practice the people were sitting up
and he did more direct teaching of
skills on how to relate to people how to
tolerate your partner he did some real
behavioral things regarding its actual
sexual problems like say if you had
premature ejaculation that's very
behavioural so he was giving the one
practice the one clientele these very
specific recommendations and he noticed
they were getting better well the people
in the psychoanalytical lying down
coming in three times a week were and
that's when he began to say hey you know
maybe I need to kind of break away from
the chains of psychoanalysis and he
turned to his lifelong passion which was
philosophy and so he really integrated
ancient him on our philosophy to create
a more efficient psychotherapy yeah but
he there was a lot of resistance at
first yes yes people would actually at
professional conferences say you're
gonna injure people you're gonna hurt
them huh
you're you're going to not help them but
there was actually accusations and he
would injure people by helping them
think differently about things
interesting
but the evidence bore out the opposite
right and one of the the big shifts that
now has a you could say cognitive
therapy approaches are riding high in
psycho psychoanalysis is kind of yes yes
yes has to do with yes yes cognitive
behavioral therapies lend themselves to
a empirical investigation and as a
consequence they have gained
predominance in the psychotherapy field
with the exception of some places niche
places like New York New York City
there's still some even though RBT was
founded in New York there are still
certain areas where their psychoanalysis
whole people hold true to the model even
in in the University of Pennsylvania
there's some still people that are
interested in cycling in Philadelphia
and cycling walking yeah but for the
most part the cognitive behavioral model
has moved towards predominance because
of the zeitgeist which is to document
for that the psychotherapy is actually
making changes so it's an evidence-based
approach yeah so how did you get it well
um okay so I always thought to help
yourself you had to clean your glasses
because I wish were glasses so is it an
athlete I would get upset if I didn't
play well particularly baseball and so I
had this into an intuitive idea that you
had a look at things differently in
order to feel better yeah what happened
then I went to the University of
Pennsylvania I had the good fortune of
actually working with Tim back I read
cognitive therapy and emotional
disorders as a student ran over to his
lab kind of worked my way in became his
scribe so I would sit next to him as you
are to me and during group supervision
for two years I'd write down every word
the man spoke about with his people he
were training so I learned
yeah that's cognitive therapy but then
at a conference I was introduced to
Albert Ellis and radius' Abbey who who's
the director of training for Albert
Ellis at the Alberto since
and I was kind of brought over to that
model and as I got formally trained in
rebt I found it more to my liking yeah
why was that well what are the features
of it that well well both of them target
cognitions but they at the outset target
different cognitions different
cognitions that are at the different
different level of analysis so in
stoicism you'll have impressions and and
they're more like Beck's automatic
thoughts so if right now I might you
might be saying like he's doing a lousy
job that's an automatic thought well my
my view but okay okay but you might have
an impression that enters your mind yeah
or you might say he's doing a good job
but in any event it's the evaluation of
that impression that really already be
talks about so say for example I said to
myself I'm doing poorly I'm doing lousy
and then I said oh my god I have to do
perfectly well there are else it's awful
RBT doesn't go after the inference the
the assumption or the perception which
is based upon the impression I'm doing
poorly what are you T wood going after
is a deeper level of philosophical
cognition which is I have to do
perfectly well and it's awful if I don't
yeah
now Beck's cognitive therapy at the
outset will go after inferences like how
do you know you're doing right why don't
you poll people and see what they think
after the fact so he's going to
encourage people to be skeptical of
their impressions now the only and then
later in therapy after ten sessions
he'll begin to kind of go down to deeper
level schema so he starts with a a
assumption that there's a distortion in
processing yeah but there's a problem
because what happens if you if if you
say for example you know I think I'm ill
I or let's let's say I I'm no no better
yet you
you say you're part of a corporation and
there's rumor that you're going to be
laid off made redundant and and the
automatic thought is oh my god I'm gonna
be caught up in this massive layoff so
Beck would say well you know there's a
there's an inference you're making which
you might want to wait to see is true
maybe you can gather some information to
see whether you're on the short list or
the long list whereas Ellis would be
more towards that well let's assume the
worst let's assume in fact that happens
yeah well let's question the idea that
it must not happen and then let's look
at how you because you tell yourself it
must not happen you must not be laid off
and it would be unbearable if it
happened it would be awful or it would
prove that I'm a loser or a failure yeah
let's question those deeper level
cognitions and see whether or not we can
inoculate you in the event the worst
case scenario happens and this is why I
was drawn to it because I like
inoculating I like inoculating patients
for a second
well that's what happens in life you
have to sometimes improvise and deal
with life doesn't work perfectly and the
rebt therapist says so what are you
going to do that's like well we have
that happen when I was recording last oh
I gotta actually we're trying to work at
these rooms you know off on the side and
we had you know permission from the
people on top but that didn't get
translated down to the people who were
going into the room and quite upset that
we were interfering with their banquet
preparations yeah well that's that's the
thing Rab G really says the work in fact
Seneca wrote about this how life is not
a dainty process and not a dinky
business not a business letters to
Lucilius and that particular letter
resonates with you because I think life
isn't dainty it will be imperfect yeah
we and already be do the rebt do and
start with the assumption let's assume
the worst does happen maybe you can deal
with it maybe you can accommodate it no
you can tell you guys get accused of
being unduly pessimistic for taking that
stance well it's really interesting you
ask that question because I think the
same thing happens with stoicism too
right people the cue stoicism oh um I
don't know
if if we get that accusation so much as
Albert was a no-nonsense type of
personality and I think some of the
criticism we got is that sometimes we're
a little bit not Durov and warm or
terribly compassionate but the funny
thing is is not everybody practices in
Albert's style so for example one of the
leading rebt practitioners is Wendy
Dryden and he was speaking to me last
night about how the importance of
teaching people to be psychotherapists
who have real sensitivity to teaching
people not only self acceptance but self
compassion okay and so I think that we
may sometimes be accused of being too
tough minded which like stoicism might
be not for everybody's liking because it
is a it is
tough-minded approach like life is hard
I'll deal with that you know when you're
talking about the concern about the
layoffs I was thinking about that
there's a chapter in Epictetus
discourses I think it's an in book three
or four where he's walking somebody
through worries about poverty and he
says well okay so you're going to be
poor
why is that gonna be a problem well
maybe I won't be able to eat he says
well I mean runaway slaves managed to
eat so that's probably not going to be
an issue for you you mean you're not
gonna be able to eat the kind of things
you like to gonna have to eat yeah
you're going back to where Ellis was but
then he brings up that other thing that
you're talking about being a loser mmm
then he says if he doesn't use those
terms of course he says people are gonna
look at your poverty and and they're
going to feel contempt for you or you
that's what you're worried about
yeah and probably they will but you know
I'm gonna be very blunt here Epictetus
is essentially saying who gives a [ __ ]
yeah if they if they do that why do you
care how they they look at you I mean if
it really bothers you that much well you
can kill yourself but but don't you know
you probably shouldn't do that because
that's really really extreme over so so
so that's classic rebt insofar as we're
gonna argue when people reject you it's
not their rejection that is as
problematic as the self rejection the
self define definition you give yourself
now you have to understand that there
are practical consequences of rejection
and our DBT is acknowledging them but
then saying look it's the emotional
consequences that we can inoculate you
from whereby you accept yourself even if
you're rejected and then you deal with
the practical consequences with greater
strength because you don't have the
emotional baggage
so is that realm of the the practical
like you know if you do lose your job
you probably are going to have to cut
back on not expenses you probably are
going to have people saying things about
you that's sort of in the realm of what
the Stoics called the indifference
which they said mattered yeah yeah you
didn't you didn't just say well they
don't we don't care about them at all
because I need to be a cynic rather than
a a stoic right but they had that sort
of two-tiered thing so is that something
that you could say is there in our abt
there's that top well it's called the
top level where you're concerned with
the the person's emotional response and
the assumptions that they're making and
then there's the the realm of the
practical where well if you do lose your
job you're probably going to suffer in
some respects well well first of all in
our abt we call a preferred we encourage
people have preferences yeah we'll say
that people look you know you want to
have you keep your preference but give
up your dogmatic demands that you must
have it easy or that this calamity must
not happen to you are somehow special
but we do acknowledge that the practical
inference that you may lose our your job
is something that you want to
acknowledge exists and then address so
that you can be ahead of the axe if
you're going to lose your job it would
be better for you to be looking for a
job and to do that with a certain amount
of equanimity rather than do it with
paralysis because you're so anxious so
does rebt have something similar to like
the stoic you know pre-med etat CEO more
thinking ahead of time absolutely
absolutely
that's a great question or EB Albert
used to do with these public
demonstrations where he would do a
psychotherapy session for society and he
they had he had what was called rational
emotive imagery and what with this was
aimed at was people going home he would
take them through it so I can take
dessert you know so what I want you to
do is let's assume you think you're
gonna lose your job okay and what first
of all let's assume that you're gonna be
anxious about that and and perhaps even
angry and let's let you or or shameful
and then let's get you first to get
yourself really upset about that which
shouldn't be that hard because that's
your default kind of response to I'm
gonna lose my
my jelly oh my god what am I gonna do
and people gonna think that you know
somehow I'm a loser yeah well so do you
want me to like try to do it well so you
you have the person I have a hook that
would work for me I you know I I'm
divorced and I pay child support
okay and so if I don't pay child support
I'm a bad dad right right and if I lose
my jobs are diversified it's a lot of
different income streams but let's
assume the worst and everything dries up
so that I can't pay per month what I'm
supposed to pay and I'm a deadbeat dad
okay so so that's the automatic thought
that you would have right and and well
you would have the inference that you
you you wouldn't be able to pay the
child support and then you would define
yourself a deadbeat dad now that really
is a role deadbeat dad okay but here's
the question is whether you then
evaluate your human worth as lesser
because you can't play the role as well
as you like and what most people will do
is say not only did I lose my job and
can't pay the child support inference
one but then it may it's true the data
supports it next in the cognitive chain
you say I'm a deadbeat dad which really
translates into I play the role poorly
right now and then you might go and say
and until I save myself and resume
normal payments I'm lesser of a person
this proves I'm somehow inadequate yeah
so people like to diminish their human
worth or rate their human worth so if
you were doing the Prima Theo Maduro
malorum of rebt which which is called
rational emotive therapy we would say
okay so what's the problem about being a
deadbeat dad is it the feeling of shame
and other people knowing this would it
be the reaction your children have we
first need to clarify what the feeling
is that you would experience so what if
it was connected with thoughts of my
children are going to suffer because of
that okay so it could very well mean
then that you would have English
I attend ok ok ok so now what we're
going to say is that what we want to do
is make a distinction between anxiety
and concern because the truth of the
matter is is that your children probably
will suffer to some extent and they're
going to be uncomfortable they're gonna
have discomfort yeah ok and what you're
doing is getting anxious about their
discomfort and the first thing we're
going to try to show you is that your
anxiety is not going to help you find
work whereas concern would be better
because concern would really help you
look for work but at the same time
perhaps you would live better during the
period of time that your children were a
little bit uncomfortable concern would
feel different - yes it would feel
different it would it would acknowledge
that there's a threat just like anxiety
but the difference is that it would say
the the cognitions behind the feeling so
remember we're talking about feelings
I usually point to my gut and cognition
so the cognitions for anxiety and
concern would be very different and what
we would do in rational emotive imagery
is to get you to first get yourself all
work up which should be easy because
that's your default response when you
think about this clamp if somebody
doesn't get worked up enough to go kind
of product no no no what you would do
then and say well there's not a
therapeutic issue to treat there's no
there isn't it's like kind of like in
sports where there's a good no foul it
looked like a penalty but it really
wasn't a penalty well there's nothing to
treat here okay you're not getting
worked up about it you haven't a half
because rebt
argues that life is rough and you're a
healthy negative emotion so if you're
then CERN right that's a good lead-in to
something I was going to ask you about
in relation to stoicism and rebt because
stoicism you know there are some some
good emotions that are the core lots of
bad emotions but one that's missing that
Cicero talks about quite a bit is pain
right there or sorrow or grief there's
no good pain or sorrow or grief or the
Stoics
and Cicero feels that's that's probably
wrong and parsing somebody who really
knows grieved Ellis would agree with
Cicero see we make a distinction between
sorrow healthy sorrow and unhealthy
extended but we could then call and
healthy grief yeah so you could either
make a distinction between healthy grief
and unhealthy grief and thereby Ellis
agrees with Cicero that the negative
emotion is inevitable there's another
one that Cicero and the storks agree
about and I know that our abt has a
different take on it which is anger
there the Stoics it's a zero tolerance
angers never good Cicero says that's
that's one thing that Stoics definitely
right and I I'm myself more Aristotelian
when it comes to that I use a lot of
stoic stuff but I know that that the
rebt people teach that there is some
healthy anger right well yeah it's
interesting because Ella's really took
the approach the more closer to the
stoic so he was a anger is never helpful
it's always self-defeating and you
better feel appropriately annoyed when
people misbehave okay now here's what
happened that sounds like a distinction
was intended right and and and in
subsequent to his death I think some of
the leading trainers in psycho third in
our DBT psychotherapy like raiding is
epi
Wendy Dryden myself we began to think
about this idea like well does annoyed
resonate with people so for example was
Nelson Mandela annoyed in in in when he
was in prison yeah and so what we then
began to use is the distinction between
healthy anger and unhealthy anger so
what is the difference how the anger
would be anger that allows you to pause
plan and then not undermined your long
term goals by trying to change whatever
you can change whereas unhealthy anger
very often leads to over-the-top
responsive excessive use of force to the
loss of perspective right yes
so if you're going to be in print in
jail
healthy anger is gonna lead you to bang
your head against the wall
yeah healthy anger is gonna lead you to
sit there and perhaps like fantasize
about what it's like to be out of jail
and what you would do if you're out
almost like Epicurus talked about on
your final moments to review your life
when you were comfortable so healthy
anger would allow you to be calculating
and coping while you were imprisoned
rather and it resonates with people
better and say well just be annoyed or
displeased yeah
that makes sense to me are there other
negative emotions that I mean the
stomach's had rational fear that caution
oh yeah this know we said caution and
our Beatty talks about concerned versus
anxiety so yeah we have a healthy
we have many we have eight basic
distinct emotions that we distinguish
Aristotle one of the things that he
talked about that was quite interesting
was so he thought that enemy was always
a sign of bad character but he talks
about something else that he calls
emulation yes we have that distinction
so and that's when you feel pain because
you would like to be like somebody else
who's achieved something but you
recognize that they did it and as an
academic and you prepped me finally you
may have had this experience many times
too or you read a book and you're like
man I wish I'd written that book well
here's here's that's so true and here's
some distinction I make okay there's I'm
healthy Envy
yeah and healthy Envy now what's the
difference in unhealthy Envy what do I
want to do I want to somehow take what
you have denigrate denigrated and damage
it maybe or damage your reputation yeah
and healthy Envy I might actually
solicit you as a model or a coach or a
teacher
okay because I acknowledge that you do
some things very well and I have healthy
so you can call it emulation but I like
healthy Envy because it's saying look
you've earned it now teach teach me to
cultivate that in me so I have healthy
the four so take for example one of my
mentors Mike Wendy dried it and this
guy's really a very articulate writer
prolific writer and you learned from
people healthy envy is healthy unhealthy
envy leads to trying to undermine your
the person who you think has what you
would like that you know with the
distinction between jealousy and and me
that I find my undergraduate students
almost always are totally mixed up about
yes
is there a correlate to to jealousy
that's a healthy form yes yes I think
it's analogous to concern so I think so
so first of all I have to again credit
Wendy Dryden because I think that he
really has been a campaign to educate
people and the difference between envy
and jealousy so let's just quickly show
that jealousy has more to do with trying
to control or or or exception yeah
jealousy does and it can be the problem
in a lot of relationships and you try to
control your lover you will try to
exclude them from others and you will
view threat it's almost to me
unhealthy jealousy is a little bit like
anxiety and healthy jealousy is a little
bit like concern so for example if I
have healthy jealousy right what I'm
gonna do is try to treat my partner well
so she's disinclined to run off with
somebody yeah I was laughing because I
had a I've got a friend who he has his
own computer company and early on when
we were just talking about this when we
were in our 20s he he had this proposal
that he was gonna offer paying benefits
so good that nobody could afford to
leave you know yeah well that's pretty
admirable
I mean he's interesting because he's
doing something
yeah he's incentivizing people to stay
by playing to their preferred
indifference but you know I should just
go back not that we have to do it but we
will talk a little bit about prima donna
and malorum and then drift it we talked
about rational emotive imagery is being
very similar so what we do in rational
emotive imagery is try to get people to
first imagine their worst case scenario
like in prima dot io malorum but then we
say to them look instead of feeling
anxious or the unhealthy emotion switch
it to a healthy emotion and keep the the
calamity constant so you keep the
calamity constant but first you get in
touch with your anxiety and then you
shift it to a healthy negative emotion
yeah and you let people sit with that
and practice that and when they do what
happens is they begin to get good at
thinking rationally cuz the only way
you're gonna convert unhealthy anxiety
into healthy concern is by changing how
you think when a cognitive level so it's
like prima donna and malorum in my view
is a little bit laissez-faire in the
process where re Beatty tries to
actually lead you through the product
through the process by saying now you
know encouraging you to change to a
specific emotion or a pyramid idea
malorum just as as far as I understand
it to imagine the calamity and
desensitize yourself yeah you can say
it's underdetermined because it gets
applied in different ways by different
people so I mean I've used it with with
clients doing you know anger management
things with them where sometimes it
would it would be thinking about it much
more broadly but then sometimes would be
very focused you're going into a meeting
with this person who you know wants to
push it buttons because these are all
executives to poke at each other and
this guy that I was working with him
thinking about in particular he he
actually had a pretty good handle on his
anger but the thing that he was bothered
by is he would get into situations where
they'd get competitive and then he was
not as articulate as he wanted well
that's the problem with unhealthy anger
you you you it's inefficient so our B
team really tries to teach you to Henry
and mote efficiently yeah so I would
have him
do do that you know about five minutes
before you go into a meeting well let's
go as well as the longer-term thing and
he found it useful to prepare him exam
in there cut you were preparing well I
think athletes do that too they actually
do a slightly different version of
imagery exercises where they actually
like a professional baseball player may
picture themselves thinking about doing
it right
yes where where it's a different kind of
imagery but here you're really doing it
very much like I don't already Beatty
therapist yeah and you know the other
thing that I think often gets left out
of the the premeditation malorum that I
mean it's right there with Epictetus is
when we're thinking about it we Pitino
says we should think about what
resources we actually do have to to cope
with what the thing that's that's coming
that's a little in well let me think
about that for a moment when you do
promote the I describe your month day
malorum
as kind of building calluses so you can
cope with the worst case scenario yeah
so for me I've done it a lot with my
wife because it's I don't we don't have
children if she were the path ahead of
me she's a little bit older than I am
that would be very very my darkest hour
and and and I think that by by by when
when I do that prima doctor malorum I do
exactly that I say to myself well not
only will I be able to survive it but
here are the ways I mind I have good
friends yeah I also have good skills so
after a period of appropriate grief
healthy grief I would new I excuse me
unhealthy after a period of healthy
grief I'd move on yeah and and and and
use these healthy skills I have to find
new love Albert used to say from old
love grows new French proverb yeah you
know
Epictetus often gets a really slammed
for that it's very early on in the
enchiridion right where he says if
you're fond of something find it useful
you know anything like that then
remember what its nature is then when it
breaks you're not going to be bothered
so when you kiss your wife or your child
remind yourself that they're mortal then
you're not going to be so upset when
they die and people look at that and
they're like well clearly it doesn't
love his wife or child but it says right
there you know fill a store get you know
whatever you are fond of whatever you do
already feel affection towards and I you
know we've talked about this like in
these stoic fellowship meetings and it's
really interesting because we keep
having the same conversation and I'd
like to get your take on this where
people seem to think that unless you're
unless you're really upset let's really
bent out of shape you didn't really love
the person well actually that's a great
question first of all I think going back
to Epictetus that what that advice gives
you when you remind yourself that your
wife is human yeah it helps you then
change your behavior in the present
that's true so I think it actually can
can be evidence that well she's human
she's gonna die so let me let me savor
the moment the good times the savor the
moments now so so you can look at it the
way you want with your bias but my bias
is that Epictetus is a realist and
saying look acknowledge ya and save her
I I think that I actually think that
what I think Jesus is saying is great
cuz he is saying you do love them you do
feel affection yeah yeah but what so why
is it that so many people you think do
think that unless you unless you're you
know going to the funeral and and
wailing yeah well are you doing dramatic
things like you know banging on the
casket or things like that
it's a great good really care you know
huh how did we get that I mean there's a
lot of cultures that do that in very
ritualistic ways in the meaning of the
breast well I think that one reason that
that might exist and against we're over
generalizing so but but but people have
this crazy idea that by inventing your
emotion it's almost like a mechanistic
model if I have anger or or grief and I
and scream that I smell let this get it
up vitia are gonna see you're actually
reinforcing that this is awful it must
not happen I can't stand it
what was me so in that wailing you gotta
be careful because we look when they
when the shock if you if I just got a
phone call right now and you told me
like my wife was in an accident earlier
today I got crushed in a London stop by
a bus I might a move but then but then
you're talking three four or five days
later it's like I think as a stoic and
as an RBT philosopher I would say to
myself look these things happen and I
need to accommodate this and and and and
by Rhian Herzing that I that this must
not care this must not occur I'm
actually I'm I'm venting but I'm
strengthening the irrational thinking
you know you're not actually sort of
keeping the memory of the person alive
by by doing that either
right I think so maybe some people think
that they're oh they feel guilty if they
don't do that there's like it continues
the attachment well I mean you know
everybody might there might be different
reasons for different people I I like
like if you don't do that then you don't
make this public display and you get
you're not you're not you're feeling
guilty because I'm supposed to do that
yeah well where's that written that's
one of the ask for rebt we target it
there's you're supposed to grieve that
way yeah you know people will come in
and say something really bad happened
and and my friends tell me I'm supposed
to be like feeling this way and I'll say
no how do you feel and then we'll talk
about their their their point of view
about it and their philosophy know maybe
there's nothing to treat your friends
are the ones who have the problem not
you yeah I was just thinking you know my
mother died when I was 29
she was only 53 she died in a rafting
accident down in Costa Rica on a river
that was you know waitress wall and
another person died too and there were
all sorts of other interesting factors
and you know she had been a thrill
seeker
and kind of you know all over the map
kind of person since I was a kid and I
had I had not done it with the purpose
of like you know hardening myself
against it or were doing you know any
sort of training but I thought to myself
what would I do and when she died if I
if I found out that something had
happened to her you know that I'd seen
lots of movies or people you know they
push everything off the desk they get
very angry and I thought maybe I would
do something like that but then when I
got the call from the console because
that she was in Costa Rica I remember I
didn't I didn't do much of anything and
I was kind of surprised by it because
I'm I'm a person that part of the reason
I got an anger management work and to
begin with was you know to try to
unscrew myself up a bit and I was very
surprised at how how I was able to
handle it and I wonder if thinking about
that ahead of time hadn't helped out in
some way I can't imagine how it would
enough I mean it inoculates you it
prepares you it we I mean it's
problem-solving in advance so the
example when we plan we think about
contingency plans well now we're just
applying contingency planning to
something that is quote unquote
unspeakable like the death of your
mother yeah are there bad ways that that
gets done only like halfway in our
culture and then you know it doesn't
inoculate people actually sort of makes
it worse for them when things happen
well I that's a great question I
personally and clinically have not ever
experienced that okay
now but I it's conceivable because
people are so creative that they can
they twist a good thing and make it
problematic like you could rehearse the
irrational thinking in an imagery like
oh my god this is a waffle what am I
gonna do I'm not gonna let it
the end of this so you actually do that
but when we at least do the rational
emotive imagery we're telling people
look you can get the concern now figure
it out and if they don't we'll then
we'll say to them look this is how you
could do it but we first try to get them
to figure it out on their own yeah so
yeah I conceivably yes but clinically no
I don't find too many people and I tell
you the truth like I may have heard
through Massimo Massimo or Greg Lopez
some research that would suggest you can
actually practice something like pre-med
doctor malorum in a negative way if my
memory serves me correctly but to be
honest with you I was not familiar with
the research hmm and I clinically have
never experienced that so I think that
okay I think when people do imagine the
worst case scenario well I guess you
people who are worriers imagine that's
what they're doing they're imagining
some some lousy thing happening and then
getting themselves all worried about it
so yeah it does make sense I guess you
could I mean you know Bill Irvine was
was talking about something like that
with his concerns about how we take
insults mm that that in some areas
people are being more primed to take
insults oh geez
I mean I would beg to differ
I think that what you're really doing is
arming people with important
psychological judo to respond
effectively and I I beg to differ I
don't think I think what you want to do
is teach people who have appropriate
sorry but I think I don't think you're
saying that about rebt I think he's
saying that about yeah cases where
people are being sort of like told
here's the things you need to look for
as microaggressions
and they're not being given any
structure other than that other than
microaggressions are always bad so you
should anticipate if you're going
let's say you're gonna go to a rural
truck stop as a typical college kid you
should imagine that people are gonna
look at you funny and probably call your
name is behind your back and things like
that and and if you could you could do
that in a very good way and say well
they probably are gonna look at you
funny because you know you're not
blending in there but you could also say
they're gonna do that here's where the
bad inference would be and that's
because they hate you or you know
they're out to get you or something and
so he's saying that bill is saying that
that you're somehow priming people
though yes back that bill was very
worried that a lot of campus culture was
with steering students towards that and
I think it depends completely on what
yeah I mean I think to some extent
that's possible because I think what we
don't do is I think we externalized
responsibility and we do a good job of
kind of trying to teach people decorum
yeah but they corn breaks down and
that's the problem with assertiveness
training I can say to you please don't
talk to me that way still may so now
we're back to how am I going to respond
internally to you treating me poorly
yeah so I mean so I agree with Bill to
to the extent that it's fine to
encourage college students to treat each
other nicely but I think it's you want
to give them a double-barreled message
and when they don't here is how you call
it hair is how you cope with that yeah
so I think you cover your bases rather
than immediately running to some some
authorities figure drying things right
and I would agree that you need to
prepare people to cope with things going
poorly in the social world yeah and and
you can't get people to always treat you
nicely so here's how what we're going to
do I think we need to teach our children
this
yeah to inoculate them because we want
them not to be fragile we do want people
we also want to teach people to be nice
to each other and not say things that
are hurtful but inevitably fallible
humans will do this so you know and we
don't want to say to the people who are
whether they're you know motivated in
some sort of bad way or they're just
making mistakes we don't want to say
well we're not accusing these people so
when you act like a jerk it's not good
affect them so much so so it's not
really that big of a deal that you're
you're behaving badly no it's a big idea
it's a big deal and let's condemn your
behavior yeah not you for doing it and
now that you've misbehaved
let's either teach you how to behave
properly or penalize you
so you inhibit whatever yeah impulse
kind of got the best of you so I'm very
much into contingency management where
you want to incentivize people to act a
certain way so it you know so it's very
complex you want to inoculate them the
person who's the target and prepare them
in case the worst case scenario happens
but then the other person and you want
to have a philosophy towards the
offender of condemn the sin not the
sinner and then teach them to act
differently both through modeling
perhaps and also contingencies behavior
therapy works do you think that with
with that that issue of condemned sin
not the sinner do you think a lot of the
proverbial centers in these cases mix
that up so they almost automatically
take condemning their actions as
condemnation of them as as persons hey I
think you're right because but what
Albert would argue is it's on I the way
I describe it is it's almost a design
flaw of the mind that when we use the
verb to be and they I did poorly there I
am bad so so so it it gets into what's
called Alfred Korzybski talked about
yeah about general man six the area and
and argue how what we do is we
very easy and whenever we use the verb
to be we then over-generalized and some
of isin I I am bad I I'm really over
generalizing rather than just say I
acted badly and I think when you do talk
to people I often tell this to my
patients look not the rest of the world
doesn't know our abt so when you
criticize their behavior what they're
gonna do is saying oh god he's
criticizing my behavior that means he's
condemning me so you need to be careful
and make it very clear that look Greg I
I like you I don't like what you did
this time today try better tomorrow yeah
so you need to be I think you're right
people do quickly convert criticism to a
condemnation yeah and I think that's
almost human nature you know that comes
right out of our EBT theory and and
problems of language yeah so I wonder
you know again the news Epictetus both
some of the other stomachs say this too
if you practicing stoicism you shouldn't
go around telling everybody that you're
doing philosophy and here now you've got
a new thing that's like totally
revolutionize in your life and you know
the way people do but if they ask about
it then that's fine I imagine there's
probably something like that for for
rebt
right yeah you don't go around saying to
everybody I've got this thing that now
it's gonna fix everything
well you're right in a way okay but but
but so for example you definitely would
we would argue the best rebt
psychotherapists are the ones who
practice what they preach so yeah I want
to model that and and I often tell my
patients look you want to model this for
your children for your wife for your
brother but on the other hand we can
sometimes say to you one of the best
ways to really learn or EBT is to teach
it to someone else
yeah you don't go around teaching it to
people without their interest or
willingness so
sometimes you you you you you need to be
careful but we will encourage people to
actually say to people look you know
there's a different way of looking at it
would you can I show you how to think
differently about this yeah so so so so
on the one hand I get I get what what
epictetus is saying like stealth
stoicism yeah and I think that's great
because really the emphasis is
consistent with what Benjamin Franklin
said a good model is the best sermon so
you know you really well with emptiness
it's interesting because you yeah I mean
the enchiridion is is I mean both of
these the discourses and the enchiridion
are arias is rearranging of what he
thought was the most important stuff
because that patinas himself didn't it
and write it down and you know that that
passage and well there's a couple
passages like that in the end karidian
but then Epictetus himself is teaching
in in school
and he's not gonna hold back and say oh
you know I'm gonna keep the stoicism
under wraps here you know he's gonna
give them full-bore a time and place for
everything and a lot of times it's a
matter of context you know and judgement
yeah come back to something you were
talking about the very beginning with
being the scribe yeah that I I didn't do
that myself but one thing that I've done
a lot of his translation work and when
you at one thing I really like about
translation work as a writer is you
don't have to have any original thoughts
of your own you just take somebody
else's stuff and try to figure out how
to avoid from France or German or Latin
into into English adequately and you're
really learning that way well that's
what I was gonna say is I imagine that
there's something very similar to to
being a scribe like that to being a
translator you have to you think about
what they're saying as you're putting as
you're putting it down as you're as
you're I mean you're transcribing rather
than translating but it is a form of
translation well you're being more
active in the processing of it right so
you're you're you're having to say okay
dr. Beck said this
and and he advised this and and and so
you're you know that's when I take notes
I do that at lectures a lot of times
because it keeps my head in the game I'm
actively processing whereas when you
listen to a guy to add identity
presentation you start kind of getting
passive and you know internalized
information so patients during a session
want to take notes like oh go ahead
these are actively or will have them
tape it sometimes and listen to their
tapes but yeah can I make one point that
I think that important so you have to
die economy of control which i think is
an amazing concept and it's just so
useful clinically in order to keep we
have an idea called the principle of
emotional responsibility which is kind
of it overlaps with the dichotomy of
control it's slightly different but the
way I teach people this idea like look
there are things you can control those
things you can one of the things you can
control is your attitude towards what
you can't control
oh that's good yeah so ya can control
your attitude towards what you can
control so I can't control you Greg I
may not even be able to control me
sometimes like so for example there are
some mistakes that you may make that our
motor mistakes like right you may if
you're a baseball player swing at a ball
on the dirt and so you you kick you
might not even be you you know you might
as a fallible human make a mistake well
yeah and do is control your attitude
towards what you can't control
I think that there isn't anything
explicitly like that in stoicism but
there's something similar which is
crisis or using or dealing with things
that are outside of our control I mean I
picked you to stress is that just
because something is is strictly
speaking outside of our control and an
indifferent doesn't mean that we we
shouldn't do it right you know but it
doesn't go he doesn't go that that far
with how we ought to think about yeah
and I so so so so so people for example
will often try to fix someone else
then fix themselves and their attitude
towards what they can fix so yesterday I
bought a card at Notting Hill that said
if you want to change a man you have to
do it while he's in his nannies meaning
and it had a picture of a baby a woman
home so in other words it was this idea
that really influences more you know you
can't change people's really you can't
change your man I think is what it was
saying you know so that's that's
something before we run out of time I
want to ask you about and this is a
broad topic I've been thinking about for
quite a while there is more malleability
early on you know but when people people
do change later in life but it's very
contingent about when they'll be open to
it and it seems like you know we can say
well oftentimes it's associated with
crises
you know something shakes up like they
lose a job or there's a divorce or
something like that and then then maybe
they're a bit more open Japanese but I
mean do you have do you have any idea
about what makes adults more open and
willing to intentionally change their
life
that's a great idea a great question I
think well they let me just think about
this long discomfort tolerance attitudes
like you know it's too hard to change ya
tend to kind of clash with reality
during crises okay and there's a window
of opportunity what is sometimes
referred to as a teachable moment yeah
and that seems to be shortly after a
crisis so for example with people who so
you're asking me when they're interested
in change or not interested there was
more about if there's any sort of way of
figuring out what the dynamic is that
opens people up to changing to being
receptive to being given tools well I I
think in psychotherapy what opens them
up is
a strong therapeutic alliance whereby
you try to show people that what they're
doing is undermining their long term
goals and you try to show them that
although they may say it's too hard to
change it's even harder to stay the same
okay
and so a lot of times you can deliver
this message easiest when there's an
interaction between what you're saying
and what's happening so take for example
a person who gets a DWI okay a lot of
times if they get injured say in a car
accident the that's a teachable moment
or if they get busted in they're in jail
that shortly after they're dismissed is
a teachable more like you know maybe you
drink too much maybe this might be a
time for us to think about how this is
impacting your life and that oh no like
it's too hard to change might be like
hmm maybe that's not such a bad idea
given that I spent the last yeah so
there's an interaction I think I think
what facilitates it is external events
but then I think people can facilitate I
wouldn't be a psychotherapist yeah
there's a psychologist if I didn't think
that I could somehow teach people let me
ask just another question then before I
give you like the the chance they have
the sort of old last thought so there's
there's a lot of talk about using AI to
take over all sorts of human tasks you I
don't know if you remember there was one
of the early not actually a eyes but
attempts to mimic AI was called Eliza
and it was it was a psychotherapy
program and it would essentially take
what you said say take a string like you
say I'm upset today and then it would
you know put in things like how do you
feel about the fact that you're upset
today and it wouldn't actually do
anything and it was just responding
mechanically but you know AI is getting
very sophisticated do you think there's
do you think there's a very risk of AI
being able to step in and
bide psychotherapy or is that something
that really only a human can provide
that's a great question and I am of two
minds so I know that sounds like I'm not
gonna be an answer but I'll point out
that so first of all the shame element
when people have issues that they're
shameful oh god they might be able to
use AI if they trust that the database
is not gonna be passed around yeah
because they're not talking to a human
so they can actually go into whatever it
is that they're very shameful because
I've had patients that don't want to
talk to me about something I think the
elephant in the room because now a shame
element and that's when you have to
circumvent that through showing them
that you have unconditional other
acceptance for them and we grow this
what they're gonna tell you yeah but on
the other hand I do I am a bit skeptical
I think I'm very very skilled like I've
been at this 28 years and and I I just
think that the ability to express and
teach although a I might get very
sophisticated I'm somewhat skeptical
that it'll work as well as a human a
well-trained human that's where what
you're talking about you know when they
do that that's the point you know there
have been studies a long time ago there
was a study where you could like have
women who were housewives in the 50s I
think or 60s do psychotherapy and the
outcome was the same as professionals
that were psychotherapists I don't know
the details of the study but I've always
been very skeptical I do believe that
that we learn now there is some evidence
to suggest that if you ask every cycle
every still tell you there tell you
they're above average well if every
psychotherapist tells you they're above
average what's that tell you attends you
to breathe air all kidding ourselves but
but I am skeptical that do you I think
we're running to make AI do everything
and I'm not so sure about this sort of
thing yeah I'm a little bit skeptical or
it's gonna take them quite a long time
and refinement of that software so at
least in my eye I don't think I'm gonna
be
placed by a computer but I do think that
the self-help books for example are
going to become like therapy they're
gonna be like to me John Robinson is
moving in that direction so self-help
books I think are going to change a
little bit and they're gonna be like the
future computer programs are going to be
like our self-help books they're gonna
be self-help books on steroids yeah I
don't know if still they're gonna get
quite there yeah well any any last
thoughts I think that if you I think
stoicism is a wonderful philosophy I
think it overlaps deeply with our Beatty
and if you have an interest in Sohus ism
you should expose yourself to rebt
insofar as you may find that it helps
you it's a little more accessible
initially you don't have to get past the
language but but but both of them are
action oriented and teach you very
similar ideas and so you can go to my
website our EBT dr. calm and listen to
some more about our apt there's some
tie-ins to Albert's lectures but I would
say that if you like stoicism you know I
came to stoicism through RBT the reason
I'm studying Ellis ism is because I want
to understand the roots of rebt
to me stoicism is the Latin of rebt and
so I'm also very interested in general
semantics theory yeah I work of Alfred
Korzybski because Ellis imported a lot
of courtship skis theater I got into him
through a van Voight I had enough for
the science fiction author oh oh yes
okay you know Africa's is I'm gonna he
was a brilliant thinker in fact science
and sanity is a masterpiece
yeah well then he had Hayakawa came out
yes yes a chai how a cow and he I
believe was a senator as well that's
right yes so so he took the power of
semantic precision into the Senate yeah
and but you know some
the human mind can think but we have
like you take for example the
disciplines and stoicism the discipline
of another disciplines the field of
study we have visions what tope tope
it's at oh boy hopefully so so logic the
Stoke start logic why didn't he each
logic because we're capable thinking
logically but we have to be taught in
and I don't think in our society we
explicitly teach people to think about
that in interpersonal relations really
think about me use logic in the science
classroom but we don't then say now
let's apply some of these same
principles to interpersonal relations
how do you deal with a friend who
misbehaves I think that they always
misbehave with you know so yeah well
thanks very much for there's been a lot
of fun I love talking about stoicism
rebt and and general Smith way you know
you put two stalkers together and you
know right because we're passionate
about the topics I say I could do this
all day long well tomorrow yes I look I
look started to have I'm doing something
called yeah stoic rationality in an
irrational world
yeah I'm looking forward to oh great
thank you so much yeah it's been a lot
of fun
you